TRANSMISSION OF DISEASES LIKE
HIV AND HEPATITIS.
>> Sean: $30 MILLION FOR LIP
BALM.
MAYBE I'VE BEEN DOING THIS JOB
FOR WAY TOO LONG.
THE 33 YEARS IN RADIO, 26 YEARS
HERE AND FOX.
BUT CALL ME SUSPICIOUS, I
SUSPECT THAT THE CRACK PIPE WAS
INCLUDED FOR METH AND CRACK
USERS, BUT THE PUSHBACK MAY BE
MADE THEM THINK TWICE.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> ONCE AGAIN, INTELLIGENCE IS
CHASING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT ADMINISTRATION IS MANAGING
TO BEAT IT.
THIS ENTIRE CONTROVERSY AND MY
JUDGMENT IS WHY MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS TONIGHT ARE THINKING,
YOU KNOW, REPUBLICANS AREN'T
PERFECT.
AND GOD KNOWS WE ARE NOT.
BUT THE OTHER SIDE IS CRAZY.
NOW THINK ABOUT THIS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS DECIDED TO
TAKE $30 MILLION OF TAXPAYER
MONEY FROM HIS EMERGENCY COVID
BILL THAT HE PASSED WITH
DEMOCRATIC SUPPORT LAST MARCH.
AND HE WANTS TO USE IT TO
FACILITATE THE SMOKING OF CRACK
COCAINE AND METH.
IN THE NAME OF RACIAL JUSTICE,
RACIAL EQUITY.
HIS PEOPLE SAY THAT THEY COULD
MAKE THE SMOKING OF CRACK
COCAINE AND METH SAFER.
FIRST, WHY ARE THEY USING COVID
MONEY?
NUMBER TWO, WHY ARE THEY USING
ANY MONEY AT ALL.
THERE IS NO SAFE WAY TO SMOKE
CRACK OR METH.
SOONER OR LATER, IT KILLS YOU.
THAT IS JUST A FACT.
WHERE WOULD WE WANT TO
FACILITATE IT?
WHY WOULDN'T WE TAKE THIS MONEY
AND USE IT TO HELP PEOPLE GET
OFF THE ILLICIT DRUGS?
WHY WOULDN'T WE TAKE THIS MONEY
AND USE IT TO STOP THE DRUGS
FROM COMING IN OUR COUNTRY IN
THE FIRST PLACE BY SECURING THE
BORDER.
AND WHAT DOES ANY OF THIS HAVE
TO DO WITH RACIAL JUSTICE?
CRACK COCAINE AND METH, WHETHER
YOU SMOKE IT OR INJECTED, WILL
KILL YOU.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT COLOR YOU
ARE OR WHAT YOUR GENDER IS.
LOOK, STUPIDITY IS A LOT LIKE.
IT IS VERY HARD TO DEFINE, BUT
YOU KNOW IT WHEN YOU SEE IT.
THIS IS STUPIDITY.
>> Sean: SENATOR, HOW DO YOU
SPEND $30 MILLION -- I DO KNOW,
I'M JUST DOING SIMPLE MATH HERE,
AND ALL YOU ARE BUYING IS LIP
BALM.
AND ALCOHOL WIPES, WHATEVER THEY
ARE GOING TO BUY.
$30 MILLION WOULD PROBABLY BE A
LIFETIME OVER A DECADE SUPPLY
FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
SO I DON'T BELIEVE THEM.
DO YOU THINK, AS I DO, THAT THEY
ARE LYING?
BECAUSE I THINK THE ORIGINAL
PLAN IS WHAT WAS REPORTED IN
"THE WASHINGTON FREE BEACON."
>> Sean: MAY BE
GEORGE WASHINGTON COULDN'T TELL
A LIE, BUT JUST ABOUT EVERY
POLITICIAN SINCE THEN HAS
MASTERED THE ART.
I SUSPECT THEY ARE NOT BEING
CANDID.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
ORIGINALLY THE ADMINISTRATION
SAID THEY WOULD INCLUDE CRACK
PIPES.
NOW JEN PSAKI SAID TODAY NO, WE
ARE GOING TO LEAVE OUT THE CRACK
PIPES.
BUT THEY ARE STILL SENDING OUT
KITS.
KITS THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
FACILITATE THE SMOKING OF CRACK
COCAINE AND METH.
AND THEY SAY WHEN YOU USE OUR
KITS, IT IS SAFER.
AND IT PROMOTES RACIAL EQUITY.
THERE IS NO SAFE WAY TO USE
CRACK COCAINE AND METH.
SOONER OR LATER IT KILLS YOU.
WEREN'T WE SPENDING THIS MONEY
TO GET OFF THE ILLICIT DRUGS.
AND WHAT DOES ANY OF THIS HAVE
TO DO WITH COVID AND WHAT DOES
ANY OF THIS HAVE TO DO WITH
RACIAL EQUITY OR RACIAL JUSTICE.
THERE AREN'T WORDS IN ENGLISH.
I SWEAR TO GOD, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION JUST KEEPS
KICKING ITS OWN REAR END AND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW IT, I DON'T
WANT TO STOP THEM FROM DOING IT
BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED NEW
LEADERSHIP